[Music]
welcome back to scienceclick today
how to visualize general relativity
the goal of this video is to show
different representations of the theory
and to put forward a brand new one which
i have not yet encountered although it
possesses a great number of qualities
the idea behind this new representation
is to make the best possible use of the
video format and in particular its
temporal dimension in order to
faithfully reproduce what the
mathematics tell us
in middle school and then high school we
learned that free fall can be modeled by
a force
it's the force of gravity
this force allows us to predict the
movement of objects stating that they
are attracted to each other and in
particular to massive objects like the
earth
however this description is merely an
approximation and it fails when the pull
is too strong such as the path of
mercury around the sun
it was in 1915 that albert einstein
proposed a new theory a rigorous
mathematical model which made it
possible to describe freefall more
accurately
for einstein there is no such thing as a
force that would act at a distance
it is the fabric of the universe itself
which gets distorted and drags objects
into a fall
in order to grasp this very complex
theory it is important to design
visualizations that make it more
intuitive
the representation that is most often
used is that of a large elastic sheet on
which massive objects are placed
by deforming the fabric under their
weight the more massive objects pull
everything in their direction like
marbles in a bowl
at first this image seems to have two
advantages it is very simple and
intuitive and it helps us understand
that bodies attract each other
indirectly through an underlying fabric
space-time whose geometry can be altered
however although it is extremely
widespread this way of presenting
general relativity has a large number of
problems which make it not very rigorous
in this video we will try to improve
this image by making four major changes
to begin with the image of the elastic
sheet seems to indicate that objects are
placed on space-time like marbles while
in reality space-time is the fabric of
the universe that contains them
therefore one improvement that we can
start with is to flatten objects onto
the surface
so that it is clear that they are not
exterior but contained within space-time
next one of the biggest problems with
this representation is that it sort of
explains gravity by gravity
to the question why does the apple fall
on earth this visualization seems to
answer that it is because the apple is
pulled downwards which causes it to fall
like a marble in a bowl
[Music]
but it is not acceptable to explain
gravity inside space-time
using gravity outside space-time
we hence have to find a better
explanation
in particular it is more rigorous to say
that if objects follow the well created
by the earth it is because they move in
a straight line but within a curved
geometry
when they fall objects move straight
ahead but the curvature of space-time
gives us the impression that these
trajectories are
deflected to understand we can imagine
the surface of a sphere on which two
ants would head north
at the start the two paths are parallel
and we might think that as they progress
straight ahead the two trajectories will
never cross
however the two ants end up meeting at
the north pole
this is possible thanks to the curved
geometry of the sphere on which straight
lines tend to get closer to one another
inside space-time the phenomenon is
similar and objects seem to attract each
other when they are simply following the
curve geometry in straight lines
[Music]
however this picture of an elastic sheet
is still misleading
indeed one could think that if
space-time can bend it is due to the
existence of a higher dimension
here for example the two-dimensional
sheet seems to bend into a third
dimension
in reality this is not the case and the
mathematics of relativity do not require
any higher dimension for the universe to
bend
it is therefore preferable not to
represent this sheet seen from the side
but rather from the top with a grid to
illustrate the curvature
while we're here this also allows us to
restore the three dimensions of space in
which we live
[Music]
finally the most important issue with
this representation is the fact that our
diagram completely ignores the time
dimension
space-time is an object with four
dimensions three dimensions of space but
also one dimension of time which can
equally bend and curve
faithfully rendering a four-dimensional
geometry is strictly impossible and we
therefore have to find a trick
a first idea would be to add small
clocks to our diagram at each point of
the grid
in this way the space grid becomes a
space time grid and we understand that
time can flow differently depending on
where we are
[Music]
that being said adding clocks to our
diagram doesn't give us much more
intuition and in particular we still
don't really understand what causes
objects to fall
if we drop an apple for example
why does it start to move towards the
earth
to really understand it is necessary to
remove one dimension of space to
represent the dimension of time
in fact it is the time component of the
curvature which explains gravity
with such a diagram we see that the
apple is always in motion
even when it has no speed at the start
of its full the apple is still moving in
time it progresses towards the future
when no force is applied to the apple
the curvature of space-time will
gradually bend its trajectory between a
temporal speed towards the future and a
spatial speed towards the ground
[Music]
the apple moves in a straight line but
the curvature of space-time rotates the
orientation of this straight line
between time and space
[Music]
we therefore understand that if the
apple falls towards the ground it is
because it started with a speed through
time
the curvature of space-time generated by
the earth has merely converted this
temporal speed into a spatial speed
having said that as human beings we do
not perceive the temporal speed of
objects when an apple is dropped it
appears to us to be motionless we do not
perceive the fact that it has emotion
through time
from our point of view we experience the
world instant after instant
and this diagram where objects form
tubes over time world lines is not very
intuitive
[Music]
our last step will therefore be to slice
this diagram to cut it up instant by
instant
in order to form an animation which
includes time
[Music]
the curvature of the universe which
causes straight lines to dive into the
earth becomes a movement of contraction
[Music]
the rate of this contraction is constant
and perpetual because the curvature of
space-time which depends only on the
mass of the earth is always the same
[Music]
however it is very important to
understand that the geometry does not
really contract
it's the fact that straight lines get
closer together that gives this
impression of contraction
[Music]
the phenomenon is quite similar on the
surface of a sphere the curvature is
constant on the sphere but the straight
lines seem to be perpetually getting
closer together
[Music]
it is this representation which i find
to be the most appealing for visualizing
general relativity
earth because it is very massive
deformed space-time giving it a
curvature
for us the curvature of space-time
appears as an endless contraction of the
grid
in technical terms we say that the
volume contained between geodesics
shrinks over time because of the
curvature
this grid that shrinks represents what
we call inertial frames frames in
freefall
with respect to this grid a body that is
not subject to any force will conserve
its movement
thus if we drop the apple with no
initial velocity as no force acts upon
it it will remain motionless relative to
the grid but as the grid contracts the
apple will fall
with this image of relativity it is also
easy to see that the surface of the
planet is constantly accelerating
upwards
because it is always going against the
natural movement of the grid
finally if we throw an object sideways
with an initial velocity no force is
applied on it and it will therefore
continue in a straight line within the
grid
but as the grid contracts the object is
constantly pulled back towards the earth
that's exactly how the moon orbits the
earth and the earth orbits the sun
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you